i was talking to you about um various
things that i've been doing
and i was started having one of those
conversations it was like well obviously
i'm using this and obviously that's
happening and obviously and you said to
me
well that's not obvious and i and i
realized that there's this
sort of there's that there's a hole in
the computer file catalog
other than dave brailsford very bravely
trying to say that html5 is a turing
complete language we haven't really
discussed
a lot of the the set of html5 javascript
and css
as a whole range of technologies that
are now kind of influencing everything
and much as this is old news for a lot
of people i thought this would be a good
springboard to launch some other more
specific videos from
reluctant to bring up uh professor
brailsford's uh conversation with me
all those years ago but yeah putting
that to one side
things have moved on since that
conversation aren't they well they have
and the thing is is they
they things were already in motion back
then but it's taken as ever you know
someone
invents something but then it takes a
while before it becomes just
pervasive and sort of standard practice
and i wanted to write
a plugin for premiere because i'm doing
a load of video editing at the moment
and when i downloaded the latest sort of
sdk and i was sitting there going
through doing some bits and pieces i
realized that
there's this thing that's been in
premiere for quite a while which i
hadn't noticed where you can write
panels
and effectively it's chromium
embedded and it's html5 css and
and and javascript to be able to control
these things and
this technology is just so pervasive now
and it kind of hasn't been covered at
all where do we start with this then
what's the first one you want to
want to mention well we should start by
by saying
you know there's a lot of things that
are similar in ways
and um there's certain terminology
during this so for example when i say
javascript
a lot of stuff is also done in
typescript which is a more strongly
typed version of javascript
but during this conversation when i say
javascript it could also mean
typescript and and so we can't really
get into the details of that but
i think the power of this technology is
that anyone can access it for free
i mean anybody out there who has any
kind of
computer at all can open up notepad
type in some code
and do something run it in a browser or
or download node and run it as a as a
as a terminal application and that's
what makes it powerful and it kind of
reminds me of when i was
six years old and starting on an acorn
electron i wrote my first program
you could type something press enter and
something happened and we kind of got
far away from that with a lot of coding
particularly
like windows based and consumer pcs and
now with
things like visual studio code being
just a free download and obviously
a browser a lot more compatible now than
they used to be it's really easy for
people to just have an entry point to
doing something cool and i really think
html5 css and javascript are
a really good entry point for people
who've never done anything before in the
same way that basic was on
an acorn electron or a bbc micro or
whatever back in the day
a lot of people don't realize there's
loads of places where the
html5 css and javascript
family are being used and one place that
is being used
is in visual studio code if you go out
on the net and watch these programming
videos
so many people using visual studio code
i think it's the number one
ide but that itself is based on
a thing that used to be called atom and
is now called electron
which i kind of like because of the
acorn electron link there but
that is effectively a chromium browser
running with you know html5 and css and
javascript and
you're kind of got this this desktop app
that's actually kind of like a website
in
a lot of ways and it's web technology
under the hood so the story really
starts with
the google v8 engine okay
which kind of changed everything it's a
javascript engine so
back in the day when when sort of
javascript started it was the mozilla
lot that came up it was a very simple
scripting language so that it
took the commands processed them in real
time but obviously that's very very slow
when um google were doing chrome and
chromium obviously the open source
equivalent they wrote a thing called the
v8 engine
which did just in time compiling
of javascript so it would take the
javascript compile it so it ran a huge
amount faster and of course the the
javascript then was way faster than ever
been before and actually became
something that could
could to run proper applications from
within a
within a browser hence we've now got
chrome os and all these
progressive web apps and there's a guy
called ryan dole
back in 2009 so a year later after
google would release
the v8 he took the v8 engine and said
well what if we don't use it in the
context of the web what if we use
javascript as the language and use their
compiler but we allow it to run
terminal applications like the old sort
of command prompt
on windows or a terminal on linux or mac
or whatever we allow
terminal applications to be written in
javascript
or typescript and that
that really kind of changed the
landscape for a lot of people because a
lot of people were writing websites
where
they'd have the html css javascript and
then that would talk to an api
over over the internet and that
api at the other end might be php or net
or
or you know java server page or
something like that and it basically
allowed you to
write back in code in the same language
and same style as your
front end code um and it had some really
good advantages so javascript as a
language is is
is non-blocking so a lot of a lot of um
traditional language so if you look at
something like php or net or those
those sort of languages they'll get the
first command and then move on to the
second move onto the third and it's kind
of in line and if you get to a bit where
say you have to do a database lookup it
would go off and
look up the stuff on the table and it
would wait for that and then come back
and do the next line of code and it
would yeah top to bottom down in
in the kind of linear way yeah like a
bit like basic i suppose
yeah process it like that whereas the
way javascript
is written is it there's this
there's a thing called the event loop
where it so what you do is you put
what it needs to do in the queue so you
could send something off and say
go and fetch that data from the database
and then when it's finished do this and
then while it's waiting for the database
to come back
it can move on to the next things that
it might do that are not necessarily
linked with
requiring that data so the analogy that
i've seen many times in videos on that
is the equivalent of
if you had a restaurant and there's many
tables and
you wouldn't want a server coming to the
table and saying what can i get you for
for your meal when they say i'd like
steak and chips please and then he goes
back to the kitchen and says we need to
take and chips that save it and just
waits there
with the javascript event loop and the
way they cue up the commands
the server would go to the kitchen say
he wants steak and chips and then he'd
come back and and get the order from the
next table and cue them up and then when
the steak and chips is ready it would be
put on the side
and he can deliver it back to the table
and that allows
it to get on and be able to have lots
and lots of concurrent connections and
to be able to cope with lots of little
sort of micro tasks without
being held up and then if one database
call takes a while well
javascript will get on with other things
until the database calls finished and it
will come back
which makes it perfect for web
technology
and of course someone then oh well no no
js you know that
we can have that in the desktop and we
can write apps like that and then
then someone took node.js put the
chromium browser on top of it and said
well this can be electron so you can
write desktop apps which are
cross platform and then you end up with
with vs code and you end up with skype
and you're not with all these
applications
working on this technology and people
are using them like desktop and probably
don't realize that
at the core it's just javascript and css
and
html you know it's just all the same
stuff that's powering
gmail and facebook it reminds me a
little bit of
technology that obviously and actually
i'll say happily died out
flash right it's it's it's a respect
it's interesting because
yeah flash flash was obviously it was
was a closed
system whereas this is open you know
node is open source
chromium is open source electron is open
source visual studio code that microsoft
write
is open source all of these things are
it's the simplicity of it you can get
notepad you can get any
notepad thing or whatever the equivalent
is in mac or linux you get that
any text editor and just write something
and run it and it doesn't require
a huge amount of overhead whereas to
write something in flash or do something
in flash you had to
have the adobe software to be able to
create the flash
it was proprietary right that was the
problem there right yeah it's
proprietary it's it's
it's so html5
and and that killed flash thanks to
pretty much steve jobs
not including it on the iphone and kind
of said no we don't want to go that
route this is a
and he was completely right although
people were angry with him at the time
he was completely right to kind of ditch
the flash technology so yeah
all of that has come in and replaced
what flash used to do that would fill in
but in a much more set of open standards
and and of course because of that the
whole
community has flourished and they've
taken things that were never intended
for use
outside the web and put them on the
desktop and
it's just stunning to see what you can
what you can do now
node which is really was was the key
after the v8 engine of being able to
compile javascript
node was the the thing that that broke
out of just being web technology but
then from there
you had the node package manager which
i'm sure a lot of viewers would have
used npm
which is very similar to to the way um
you'd use that get or whatever on
on on ubuntu or you'd use any kind of
repository
which allowed you to just install
whatever node module you want so if you
want something that can root so you get
a web address say
slash user slash whatever and you want
it to run this piece of code when you
get that url
you can install express you know it's
very simple one line you install that
module and it allows you and
and again it opened up um it opened up a
lot of opportunities for people who
only had been programming in web
technologies to suddenly be able to
enter
areas that they would have had to have
learned c or c
plus plus or you know c sharp or
something like that to do
the more you look round now when you
turn your tv on and you see something
come up
the more chances are that you're
actually interacting with this
web technology which really is has been
a revolution since
2008 because of google creating the v8
engine and then
node and these other sort of platforms
that take use of that v8 engine
i love the fact that you know i started
an acorn electron the predecessor to
that was the acorn atom
and now it's kind of like atom and now
electron it feels
feels like there's someone having a nod
back to those beautiful sort of early
80s days of british computing which
which just
you know just adds a bonus to me all we
need now is someone running the acorn
and the electron stuff on a raspberry pi
and the circle is complete
well i mean that's the thing you can run
i mean
many people out there i mean i've i've
written um
i've written a couple of apis that i use
to control some things at home
that are in node that do run on a
raspberry pi
over wi-fi and i can i can control
various bits and pieces i had something
which was moving the knobs on my amps
for me so i could sit down stairs and
turn
up my amp and a little motor would turn
the knob on my amp and that was
done via node things that i never
thought were possible to do
for example putting a mixing desk in a
browser and being able to have all the
channels of a song and be able to turn
up and down the bass drum and the snare
drum and
there's the audio apis that sit
underneath the browser to actually do
the hardcore stuff but you're
interacting with that with javascript
and
doing stuff that 20 years ago would have
been just
out of the league of someone like me to
be able to write you need a whole team
of programmers to do and now
you can write it in a web browser it's
it's fascinating
i've bought the rights to use that
picture in any derivative works from it
so if i then reverse engineer the audio
from that picture can i use the audio
because it came from the picture which
is in this column so sometimes we mix
diagonals so it'll be a
b c d or a
b c d